ما اطلع وايضا الاوقات الزحمه
النفسيه
بالفعل مشاهدينا الخبراء يقولون بانه يقضي
الغالبيه من الناس ما معدله من ثلاثه الى
ست ساعات يوميا في حركه المرور هذا كثير
لكن هل فكرت يوما في تاثير ذلك على صحتنا
العقليه والجسديه الخبراء وصفوا هذا
التاثير او وفق موقع
بمتلازمه الاجهاد المروريه التي تسبب
مجموعه من الاعراض صح هذه الاعراض تتضمن
الصداع والتعب والقلق والاكتئاب حتى كمان
خفقان القلب ويمكن ان تؤدي ايضا الى
انخفاض في التركيز والذاكره يعتقد ان سبب
متلازمه الاجهاد المروري هو اثار الضجه
وتلوث الهواء ومواجهه خطر الطريق فضلا عن
التوتر
على ازدحام
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات